[Music]  Oh  [Music]  I came to the elite of the elite the  heart soul are just very big issues we  protect when no one wants to protect and  we go above and beyond is something you  would say me people your refrigerator oh  that's a very wash put me it's more than  this job than just swimming Victoria  leads to new owner absolute love Josh  murder all this started once Leeds took  over I thought we were lifeguards  everything that you guys talking about  sounds like a really entertaining but  far-fetched TV show I just tell it by  running oh you see it  but you can be a great watch [ __ ]  goodnight nitrogen  grab my hand  you turn the canals into the goddamn X  game yeah that's because we were in  lifeguard pursuit with no [ __ ] such  thing as lifeguard pursuit even if you  were police what you did would still be  totally illegal okay well I mean it's  good thing we're not police  [Music]  you